Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
No handing out instances of SCP-437 as
weaponry to unsuspecting new researchers.
Dr. Bright has a real taste for Mischief,
bloodshed, and root beer floats, or,
as he calls them, the three major food groups.
New researchers at the Foundation, with their
difficulty recognizing sarcasm, often find
themselves in the crosshairs of his goofier moods.
Well one of his cruelest jokes of all time,
however, is introducing new researchers
to SCP-437 without any kind of warning.
Imagine starting a new job, and meeting
someone of a higher rank than you that you think
you can trust. This person tells you to check
out a specialized weapon, and when you do, you
find trees that have disturbingly human faces in
their bark, sap made from blood, and the muffled
sound of agonized screaming emanating from within.
Dr. Bright has been formally censured
for this behavior, and warned that if
it continues, he will be responsible for
covering all resulting therapy bills.